la rentrée en maternelle c'est souvent
bruyants c'est le coeur serré que ses
enfants de 2 ans et demi à trois ans
font leurs premiers pas dans le milieu
scolaire
quoi de plus normal un baiser de grand
mère ou de papa voire deux soeurettes
vous donne tout de même du coeur au vent
mais au fil des ans les parents se sont
mis eux aussi à pleurer départ en poule
parfois plus stressés que leurs propres
enfants
quel âge a votre fils votre fille et
deux ans et demi et alors des parents
qui pleurent qui restent scotchés aux
fenêtres de la classe pour voir si tout
se passe bien pas vraiment une bonne
idée selon cette psychologue
en 1993 il ne faudrait peut-être pas
rajouter à l'anxiété normal des enfants
l'anxiété des parents et que très
souvent l'anxiété des enfants répond à
l'anxiété des parents et non pas l'un
vers ce malgré ces avertissements les
parents ne répondent plus de rien
certains après une première journée
d'école vont même jusqu'à négocier une
rentrée plus tardive
il s'est accroché beaucoup à mes trains
[Musique]
ses parents poule ne se contente pas de
craquer seulement à la maternelle ils
sont même là pour la rentrée au collège
en réalité comme tous les ans ce sont
les parents les plus stressés tu as
quelques difficultés à trouver le
sommeil et je pense quand même que c'est
un événement donc on est à la limite
plus ému que les rentrées on se rappelle
des nôtres et on assure était anxieux
pour les notes donc
on change pas ce niveau là on est
toujours un petit peu c'est pour ça
qu'on accompagne bon courage à leurs
enfants
[Musique]